hey 42 here during the Olympic fires two
ancient Greek tank retreats essentially
wrestles were caught in a struggle for
victory and one of them are Akiane fig
alia was about to lose caught in a
stranglehold and with almost no hope of
freeing himself our Akhil
struck out at his opponent with a
terrible wild kick that he thought might
earn him a slim chance of escape but he
ended up with more than he could have
possibly anticipated the kick earned him
his victory crying out in pain from the
terrible attack his opponent immediately
signaled to the umpires that he was
defeated and Archean was victorious but
IRA Keon would never realize this
because his kick was so powerful and the
stranglehold he was caught it was so
tight that the combined force
immediately shattered his neck and ended
his life so he had met with victory but
also with death it seems that the
prospect of immediate painful and an
avoidable death is on everyone's minds
at the moment many are worried about
coronavirus killing their more to global
breakdown of society causing widespread
chaos that could result at the end of
the world but what really is the
probability of you dying today whilst it
may seem like your death is always
around the corner is that actually the
case it turns out it's not actually very
likely at all the likelihood of your own
death depends on your lifestyle your
habits your psychology and your
environment so if you're morbidly obese
addicted to PCP suicidal and live in
northern Syria your immediate chances of
survival would probably be below average
but in general if you aren't intending
to harm yourself and you aren't
currently struggling with a terminal
illness the odds of your death on a
given day are extraordinarily low the
probability as a whole is around point
zero zero zero two
which is astronomically unlikely you are
8% more likely to win the lottery and if
you were immortal meaning you didn't die
of old age you would probably live to be
over 6000 years old before your ads of
unintended fatal injury caught on TV
despite the fact that people fear
catching a terrible plague or getting
torn apart by bears the most common
causes of death aren't particularly
exciting as far as common deaths go 23%
of fatalities go to heart disease and
over 22% to cancer with Alzheimer's
diabetes pneumonia and strokes or making
an appearance we all know despite our
irrational fears that it's not very
likely we'll die irrationally you will
probably die of an age-related illness
like the vast vast majority of the world
but that's boring what if there were
ways you could die that are so strange
so bizarre and disturbing that you'd
never want them to happen to you well
there are plenty and throughout history
there have been some unbelievably weird
recorded deaths take these examples the
first emperor of China Qin Shihuang was
so desperate to grant himself eternal
life that he ingested several pills of
mercury which unsurprisingly killed him
almost immediately or there was the
ancient stoic philosopher chrysippus who
when seeing his donkey eating figs
roared now give him some wine to wash
them down he found his own jokes so
funny that he collapsed to the floor in
uncontrollable laughter had a fit foamed
at the mouth and died but now I'm sure
you're thinking that's great but I'm not
searching for eternal life and I sure as
hell don't own a donkey all I do is
sleep eat go to work come home eat sleep
and repeat how could I die of something
weird and bizarre well you're about to
find out let's start with eating it
isn't just toxic food
can kill you the odds of dying from
choking are about one in 2,600 with nuts
and popcorn being common culprits but
you can also choke on other things now
before your dirty thoughts go wild
consider this story the famous
playwright Tennessee Williams choked to
death on a bottle cup whilst trying to
take barbiturates
there's also BPA poisoning bisphenol A
is a poisonous synthetic chemical that
can cause impotence and heart disease
released into your food by just about
every plastic imaginable but worrying
about that is sensible unrealistic how
about eating yourself to death is that
possible and if so how would it happen
well yes it is a rare disease called
prader-willi syndrome motivates you to
do just that it's the most common cause
of morbid obesity you can be motivated
to eat so much that food and bile will
start to seep into your abdomen your
blood will turn septic and without
immediate surgery you will almost
certainly die in fact just this kind of
death was what happens to adult
frederick the king of sweden after
stuffing his face with lobster
sauerkraut caviar smoked herring
champagne and 14 servings of Semler and
hot milk his digestion went into
overload and he promptly died but in
consolation he is remembered by
schoolchildren all over the world as the
king who ate himself to death but maybe
you're less ghostanus than King
Frederick maybe you're more
health-conscious well fear not because
there are some healthier ways to consume
yourself to death as well take for
instance and basil Brown who consumed so
much vitamin A and carrot juice but his
skin turned bright yellow and he died of
liver damage or consider Tina
Kristofferson who in an effort to combat
stomach cancer drank 15
is of water a day and died but look if
all that doesn't frighten you just
consider that every day your stomach is
in a constant battle to not eat itself
your entire digestive system is lined in
mucus which neutralizes your stomach
acids and prevents your stomach and
intestines from eating themselves but if
that mucus fails to do its job you might
just end up eating yourself alive from
the inside out that's exactly what
begins to happen when you get a stomach
ulcer
now what about walking or traveling to
work is it possible to die doing that
well of course but if we ignore the
average of 3287 people who die from road
crashes every day around the world and
in the UK the minimum of one person who
is run over and killed daily as a
pedestrian then yes there are some other
odd ways that your commute can finish
you off
who doesn't occasionally trip over but
that's mostly harmless right well Allan
Pinkerton the founder of the famous
Pinkerton Detective Agency was walking
along in Chicago one day when he tripped
over and bit his tongue then soon after
his tongue became infected with gangrene
and he died but while simply walking to
work some truly unpredictable Black Swan
event could have very well come out of
nowhere and end your life and there's
very little you could do about it for
example one day in Boston's North End a
large storage tank burst open releasing
an enormous wave of dark syrup that
swept across the surrounding pavement
killing 21 people and injuring a further
150 it was later dubbed the great
molasses flood however if you don't
enjoy syrup you could always be drowned
in a flood of beer as happened during
London's be a tsunami in 1814 when a
brewery gave way or failing that you
could simply be killed as a part of a
strange series of completely bonkers
events that defy all explanation
has happened in Buenos Aires
unbelievably a poodle fell 13 floors and
landed on 75 year old Marta Espina
killing both of them immediately as the
terrible crash was heard
Edith Soler who was nearby ran over to
help but was struck by a bus and was
killed in the process
then another witness who was
unidentified was so shocked by what he
saw that he had a heart attack and died
as he was rushed to the hospital so you
should be okay as long as you steer
clear of poodles descending a terminal
velocity but surely you're safe when
tucked up in bed right think again one
disturbing mode of death is Suns sudden
unexplained nocturnal death syndrome it
is as the name suggests when you will
suddenly die in your sleep for
essentially no explainable reason or you
could die from undetected carbon
monoxide poisoning whilst awake you'd be
warned by feelings of dizziness or
headaches whilst asleep however you
would have no idea and the gas would
slowly suffocate you to death perhaps
even more disturbing is how common
carbon monoxide is as is present in cars
fireplaces stoves and much more
thousands unwittingly died from the
silent killer
each year around the world perhaps a
more likely way of dying in your sleep
is through obstructive sleep apnea where
your breathing apparatus is obstructed
during sleep alleys 22 million Americans
suffer from sleep apnea with countless
others going undiagnosed but it turns
fatal when you're obstructed breathing
triggers and unknown but pre-existing
conditions such as a high risk of heart
disease
and it could kill you without warning
all whilst you're asleep but all of
those are less horrific than the
following case Fulton Jones was a lawyer
in Banga Wales
one night he suffered an awful nightmare
where he had taken a knife and slit his
own throat waking up he discovered blood
pouring out of his actual neck and the
deep cut sliced into his throat with his
life rapidly flowing from his body he
reached across for a pencil and paper
and wrote I dreamt that I had done it I
awoke to find it true he died 80 minutes
later and an inquest found that he had
committed suicide while suffering from
temporary insanity so when you go to
sleep tonight you best pray that you
don't have the same awful dream now we
all spend a lot of time moving to and
fro eating and sleeping what about the
other activities during your day how
could you die doing those well it turns
out there are plenty of lovely ways
actor Anton Yelchin died checking his
mail when his car rolled down a hill and
crushed him against a brick wall
Geoff Dali and Peter Bukowski both died
suddenly and seemingly without cause
when they got a high score in the
videogame the zerg Hitoshi Makeda
and doctor in texas died at work when
his head became trapped in his workplace
elevator and it decapitated him a
fourteen-year-old boy also died at work
when the pneumatic cylinder in his
office chair suddenly exploded and
killed him Gary who died at work when
one of the building windows popped from
its frame and sent him falling 24
stories to his death and Larry Elie
Mario Moncada died did work when he fell
into a small 18 inch gap between the
water cooler and the back wall his body
was discovered when the cooler was
finally moved
almost 10 years later sergio milan died
hanging out in his flat when a gigantic
metal plate was launched by a factory
explosion flew three kilometers through
the air and crashed into his flat
crushing him Edmund Ironside died on the
toilet when an assassin hiding
underneath stabbed him to death
ouch Jonathan Cape well died as a result
of his personal hygiene due to his
obsessive use of spray-on deodorant
he had point three seven milligrams of
butane colita in his blood point to six
milligrams higher than the fatal dosage
han staining had died as a result of his
grooming habits when he tripped over his
one point four meter long beard and
broke his neck and Jimmy furrows Oh died
having sex with his girlfriend when the
grand piano he was having intercourse on
began to extend on a hydraulic motor
towards the ceiling
eventually pinning him on suffocating
him to death so yes there are plenty of
strange ways that you can die every
single day but functionally not many of
them are very likely as this has been a
rather gloomy video I want to end on one
incredible anecdote that might just make
you smile during the persecution of
Valyria when Christians were being
captured and executed on mass the deacon
the st. Lawrence was caught and tortured
over a giant grill on which he was
roasted alive legend has it that
throughout the proceedings he was such a
badass that he joked with his tormentor
saying turn me over I'm done on this
side naturally he is now the patron
saint of cooks chefs and comedians
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider supporting me
on patreon it really helped me to
continue to make these videos the links
in a description also if you want to get
your hands on a first edition signed
copy of my new book stick if like in it
a thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and Beyond then head on over to
all
bond publishing the links in the
description and get yours today thank
you